Friday Friday gotta get down on Friday
you're singing that wrong how I made it
up I thought this job would be keeping
things fun
Kimmy stuff it's Friday Oh Cheryl you
are bad I know you're just a sweet girl
who don't know how to act when you moved
in here you have boundary issues what
are we doing today I want to write an
escalator why hasn't my favorite client
been answering this phone
not like you call what good news I got
you that stock footage gig is that what
that was
[Music]
it's just gonna turn into a porno or not
and it never did Seth wants me to fire
one of the coders they never want to
make people feel sad I'm not an you're
I'm a poo I'm a big old poo there's no
good men in this dang country you
couldn't possibly understand what it is
like to be a male today like how come
when your body makes milk it's beautiful
squeeze me
Jabir filed a sexual harassment
complaint against you why I don't want
you to feel embarrassed embarrassing
stuff can happen anymore
uh-oh would you look at that work Kimi
incited
I thought this show to be special you
know what forget this I was ready to
quit back when I was in diapers it was
for an adult diapers commercial ads I
was fired you believe Vanessa thinking
I'm just another fancy white shirt you
don't know those women's lives our lives
you can't because of white privilege I
might to wait all day
I'm extremely white over here
[Music]
you